rittany Mario it'sa me Mario
what who flicks ago okey-dokey
oh I've been the voice of Mario for 26
years now arigato to reduce not moving I
don't know
[Music]
hi i'm charles martinet
I do the voice of super mario here we go
whoa
and the way you talk Luigi never mind
haha
and why oh hey about a day yeah oh you
wanna eat that garlic ah ah and I was
even Donkey Kong one boy who I am an
actor and voice actor I did gosh 25
years of theater run along to your
pocket corporate videos circuitry and
semiconductor processes a few film and
television products now feed it all you
know and then that I had the marvelous
beginning of becoming a voice actor and
that's how I started with eat any Mario
Mario was first created in 1981 in a
game called Donkey Kong as it got
refined through the years it became
Mario and Princess Peach pentanes and I
came along in 1990 I actually crashed an
audition because I was catching them as
I walked in they were walking out
finished for the day I said can I read
for this and the guy looked at his watch
and because all right come on in
you're an Italian plumber from Brooklyn
a character in a video game for Nintendo
called Mario so make up a voice make up
a video game start talking and I thought
to myself video game I don't know
anything about video games and all of a
sudden I hear action I go hello I'm
Mario kids make a pizza by together you
go get some sausage I'm looking some
spaghetti we put spaghetti in the
sausage in pizza and he said you know
cut
stop talking there's no more tape all
right thanks we'll be in touch and I
thought that was you know ok there's the
door we'll see you later and I he calls
Nintendo I found out Mario I got him and
that was 26 amazing fantastic years ago
I know hello Ruby oh look at this story
the character for me brings out the best
in me and so I love that mean mean mean
I love sharing things too I go to meet
Mario fans and I hear the most wonderful
thing you know the you're the voice of
my childhood I and I used to play with
my dad now I'm playing with my kids you
know and we just it's a way our family
comes together good hands think back the
memories Mamma Mia
you just have fun you know that's my
mantra for life come on let's go they
tell more fun bye bye see in my games is
what you journal it's me Doug I may not
be the president
yeah
on Nickelodeon in the 90s I was the
voice of Doug funnie
Roger clock ran late I mean and Stimpy
what a decade I put a tiny little bit of
my own self into each character give me
a dog funny hi everybody this is Doug
funnie oh I just searched crush on Patti
mayonnaise I was pretty much like that
at 11 years old I used to fantasize a
lot you know I could entertain myself
for hours and what about Roger
hey you're the Biggest Loser I ever saw
he was based on a bully that used to
bother me how about Ren you shut up you
fool see you
M simpie hey Ren I picked the nose
Goblin I picked it myself for you you
still entertain yourself I'm sick of
myself
you also do Futurama Philip J fry man
all's constant exposure to radiation is
making me thirsty shuttin take my money
I found it just like that when I was 25
I was all whining nasally and if I broke
a string on stage you know it's like ah
man what am I to do now
and dr. Zoidberg young lady bring me a
sandwich from the dumpster and leave the
maggots on it Wow I'm startling
Professor Farnsworth school news
everyone I don't want to live on this
planet anymore that Brannigan
she's a beautiful ship all right I'm
gonna fly her brains that good I'm very
fortunate really lucky that I can do
what I do and I just want to keep coming
to work till I tell you don't come in
anymore it is a final would ah goodbye
[Music]
you got you you've got mail you've got
you you've got mail
goodbye you all of you who thought eh
AOL was voiced by a computer now let's
set the record straight I recorded those
phrases welcome you've got mail files
done goodbye
my name is Elwood Edwards and I'm the
voice of you've got mail in 1989 my wife
was a customer service rep for the
company that was about to become America
online she heard Steve case talking to
some of the programmers about how fun it
would be to add a voice to the software
I've been an announcer throughout my
entire broadcasting career and she
volunteered me I scribbled those phrases
on a piece of paper and like I say on
the cassette deck I recorded the welcome
you've got mail files done goodbye
it started off as a test just to see if
it would catch on and lo and behold in
the mid 90s it had really caught on and
at one point they said my voice was
heard more than 35 million times a day
but the problem was I was typecast the
one thing I did do was a voice for the
census
you've got leprosy goodbye being
associated with AOL has been gratifying
even today you go on AOL comm I greet
you I greet myself
villains from 80s cartoons had a similar
sound
yo black girl but you already ran away
and there was a reason for that most
were voiced by this guy what Alan
Oppenheimer
my name's Alan Oppenheimer and I'm an
actor most famously he's the voice of
Falkor from neverending story and
Skeletor from he-man why are you asking
me these stupid questions got a life
regarding he-man Masters of the Universe
I was Skeletor I figured the voice would
reverberate inside that bony head so
that's why we went up in here nasal you
boob you idiots why are you bothering
living you've got a better life
somewhere else get out of my face
he did some other villain two choices
there doesn't seem to be some relation
there I stole for myself
I mean hey if I plagiarize myself you
know no consuming you know come in you
Ryo bull but then there was falcore
falcore was the luckdragon he's kind and
he's big and fuzzy
my name is Falco and he's flying so you
have that feel whoa
let's go a trail thing and he actually
did a few other characters from
neverending story very tasty boy whoa
warts okay
get the picture Alan's had an amazing
career for me though I like Falkor Alan
will you do the voice again the trail
get on my back and we'll fly oh they're
those police let's get them
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]